اشارت وسائل الاعلام من بريطانيا الى موقع
اشتباكات في مركز الاحتجاز طالب اللجوء
غربيه لندن
وسائل الاعلام عن وزاره الداخليه ان عدد
من المحتجزين المسلحين باسلحه مختلفه
تجمعوا في فناء مركزي هامورس الواقع قرب
مطاره وبداوا في الاشتباك دون ان تحدد
اطراف
الكهرباء في المركز والتي لا تزال مقطوعه
حتى اللحظه كما قالت وسائل اعلاميه ان
الشرطه بدات في نقل طالب اللجوء من مركز
الاحتجاز الى مكان اخر لم يعلن بعد
من جانب اخر قالت شرطه مكافحه الارهاب في
بريطانيا ان الكراهيه هي الدافعه وراء
الهجوم على مركز احتجاز طالبيه لجوء في
دبر الذي وقع في 30 من اكتوبر المنصرم
والذي استخدم فيه منفضه عبوات الحرقه
سابقا
مواطن بريطانيا
يبلغ من العمر 66 عاما ووجد مقتولا في
سيارته عقب الهجوم